en esta granja ucraniana la temporada de
cosecha se acerca rápidamente pero
muchos agricultores se preguntan Cómo
cosecharán su trigo uno de los muchos
problemas a los que se enfrentan el
precio del gasóleo
estaría bien comprar gasóleo Si lo
compramos el precio es muy alto el
precio es muy alto
para hacer Jay la guerra casi ha acabado
con su forma de ganarse la vida le ha
obligado a dejar de cultivar 40 de sus
170 hectáreas al no poder comprar la
semilla de maíz necesaria produce
principalmente trigo pero también cebada
y girasoles y la ventana para cosechar
es estrecha
aquí el trigo Ya está empezando a caerse
sabes está casi maduro y empieza a
caerse en dos semanas Estará listo para
cosecharse y se caerá tan solo con el
viento
en otra granja del mismo pueblo este
agricultor anatoly sí tiene suficiente
combustible para cosechar su principal
preocupación es que sus cultivos sean
arrasados por los misiles rusos
todo el trabajo que he hecho será en
vano he comprado grano de primera
calidad
Ucrania es uno de los mayores
productores de trigo del mundo y si su
trigo no se cosecha en agosto podría
provocar una crisis alimentaria mundial